[Music]
all right it's the matinee show I think
it's 57 maybe it's something like oh my
god
somewhere around there it's Halloween
yeah we just ended we're recording this
on Halloween now yeah actually and this
is I know it's like a new background no
exciting that says yeah this is the the
Dan we're sitting at our kitchen table
yeah yeah is this the kitchen table it's
the Copa Yeah right yeah her breakfast
again back there if you'd like to be
kind of pretentious about it yeah but
yeah we just shut down the Halloween
festivities because we pretty much ran
out of candy got something that we
wanted to like at least a couple
handfuls for us towards an end as it was
like 15 and 16 year old suck hit me up
they didn't were not even in costumes
well yeah slide up well I used to do
that but I usually don't ostium I
usually like I don't know if you guys
know but go look on YouTube there's a
song by the swinging neckbreaker x' and
it's called no costume no candy yeah
that's kind of about his policy about
yeah yeah no costumes on it he's like
just it's very very funny so you should
go check it out so let's see what do we
do this week we saw all the movies one
on shudder which is a creep show review
like we do every week we saw one on
Netflix and we saw one in the theater
yeah so the first we're going to be
talking about we're gonna be talking
about creep show the series episode 5
yeah this one was a good entry I think I
think it was the weakest out of them all
so far I tend to agree with it but it
was still good yeah it's still good
these are all decent like even the ones
light like you said I and I think that's
kind of like from other people's reviews
that seems to be kind of the consensus
is that this is probably the weakest one
so far yeah um but not bad by any means
but no so the first story was called
night of the paw and this was written by
John Esposito and directed by John
Harrison who has directed a bunch of
other segments for the show this is
actually a loose retelling of the very
very famous WWJ kabzuag ease paw but
with like a little bit of a twist type
of thing basically it's like an old guy
and he saves this woman and it's you
know there's a car accident he cuts off
her fingers that's pretty gruesome
because they're broken or whatever and
then it turns out when she wakes up it
turns out that this is a funeral home
and this guy has a monkey's paw
essentially and he kind of tells him
about the three wishes and everything
like that one thing cool thing I liked
about this was the monkey's paw itself
like as I guess each new person that
gets it like it's a monkey's hand so it
has like four fingers on the thumb
but it's little pinky is gone but it's
little fingers every time you make a
wish like his little one of those little
fingers curls up so when you when a new
person gets the monkey's probably the
wishes reset then it's little fingers on
curls so that's how you know how many
wishes you got left yeah I have to say
about this though and I feel maybe less
so than in the original story people
just as a pro tip if you ever get a
monkey's paw that gives you three wishes
be very very careful and very very
specific about what you wish for because
this monkey's paw jazz if you just say
some like random [ __ ] like oh I want my
wife back
or idea you know what she's dead and
everything like that that's not gonna
end well you have to you have to very
specifically well they say what you
wanted [ __ ] like that because that's
kind of the whole premise of this thing
and what this guy is trying to tell this
woman is that you know yeah he's white
he wished they wish for like all the
money like pretty much everyone would
and then the wife ends up dying like in
a horrible way that's how I got the
money that's how he gets the money so
life insurance right yeah no like well
you wanted money you say how exactly
what I mean so then he like wants to
wish her back from the dead but
unfortunately there's a loophole there
too that's kind of
it's really kind of the same problem or
the same thing that they talk about with
stories about jihad and Jeannie yeah is
that Jeannie's were evil yeah you know
they were entrapped for a reason yes and
they were bastards so you made a wish
she don't when I talk about Aladdin
genies that's a friendly G that yeah a
pleasant means a true genie gin all
right I think this is even free as long
as pre-islamic stuff going back into you
know into the Persian Empire
you know lore Janey's were demons yeah
there were demons that had been enslaved
by a damn wizard what would they call
the wizard what was what was the who was
a person wizard there was a name for him
but I forgot I can but
yeah so you might ask for a wish but it
was just an opportunity for the jinn to
[ __ ] you over [ __ ] you all right so you
had to be a quiet of a wise [ __ ]
sorcerer or magician to know how to ask
for a wish yeah you had to trap a genie
even into wish so you know I had to get
even that's happened you have to be like
super specific and like yeah and okay
the thing about this one like I actually
quite liked this story this was it was
kind of a weird episode because the
first segment was way longer than the
second one even though the second one
could have done with a bit more fleshing
out but I'll get to that a minute
so this was like a fairly long episode I
think I was like 25 or 30 minutes and so
this you know so this guy spends this
whole time like telling this woman about
essentially what ended up happening with
this monkeys fun like hashing how you
have to be really careful and stuff and
now she doesn't believe him at first
which you know that's understandable and
[ __ ] like that but when she ends up with
the monkey's paw she immediately does
like really dumb ass [ __ ] like here's
the thing though it's like she doesn't
believe it at first but then the the
monkey's paw seems to like I guess you
don't have to like say the wish like
right to its face like normally you
would have to thank hey I wish were in
love with LA but apparently she just
wishes for something like in her head
without say
it out loud and the paw is like okay I
can do that for you you know I mean so I
don't know what the whole rules of it
are but then like so she realizes that
it works and then at the very end she
makes like the dumbest ass wish ever
she's trying to bring her husband back
from the dead but all she says is
something like get up in a morgue right
and you can imagine how well that goes
yeah but yeah I actually quite liked
this segment a lot of boobies I read
they didn't like this one so much but I
actually liked it because they're like
look that you know the monkey's paw has
been adapted so many times at least like
a hundred times in various mediums it's
a very old story we all read it in
school and [ __ ] like that
but I thought it was kind of a twist on
it I didn't mind it and I thought it was
like night the acting was good like you
know it was shot really nice and stuff
like that so I didn't have a problem
with it you do that the whole episode
was good yeah you know it wasn't bad
it's just the weakest one so far but
still you know definitely on par with
like a good Twilight Zone episodes oh
yeah definitely
yeah I really I didn't I'm not
complaining about I'm just saying it
wasn't quite as good as two other ones
but it was still good oh and I have to
say Easter Egg for all you horror nerds
out there like me the second time I
watched this episode if you look in the
the guys the funeral home book like they
do a close-up on a per second the first
name in it is Herbert West but the
second name deep cut francesco della
morte no no that so yeah and we have to
do a review on that I love I don't think
I've seen that no I don't think you have
either it's batshit insane okay and I
love it okay I'm right uh but yeah so
there were other names too but I
couldn't read them like I sat there and
put cuz his for as soon as I saw the
first two names I was like oh X so I'm
like I paused it but I couldn't read the
other ones it was too messy but I was
just like you know so look out for that
that's kind of cute so the second
segment x is tough in musky holler yeah
this one like I said this this segment
was kind of weird because it was really
short it was only like 15 minutes long
but it seemed
like it almost seemed like it was a
longer story that they cut down to make
the first one longer because it seemed
like there was a lot more they could
have gone into cuz that for when I was
first started watching it I was just
like what the [ __ ] is going on it's like
there's all these people in a prison and
then there's all these people talking
about these crimes you committed and
we're gonna do this and that may have
them on all these chairs with chains
yeah and it's like they're gonna raise
it and I'm just like and it took a while
and it just seemed like a lot of this
story was told through like voiceover
yeah like exposition and they and a lot
of it was done in like comic panels yeah
and then what it is is that the movie
starts that I mean excuse me that the
story starts to [ __ ] kind of narrow
down and to basically something bout a
walking dead it is very walking dead
risk lice like something a local
government from The Walking Dead would
do to some people you know for betraying
the the colony behind the zombies yeah
basically and it's a zombie story but
yeah but it's almost like something
lifted directly out of the Walking Dead
it is it wasn't bad it's just it was not
not shocking by today's standards
because we have the walking dead so it
was kind of like something you'd seen
before yeah take as long to get to that
yeah which maybe that was the problem
with Walking Dead as they beat around
the bush or an entire season for for
something that actually happened
well they've kind of condensed it all
down into about 15 minutes the only
problem I had with this one was that one
it seemed like like I said it seemed
like a lot of the story was told like
kind of clunky like an exposition which
I guess that was kind of like more
indicative of you know this a fairly
low-budget show so maybe a lot of the
like stuff that they were talking about
it's like oh these zombie apocalypse
came and then this this mayor like took
over this town and started cracking down
and like killing people that didn't
agree with them and so they were getting
back at him and you know it the story
kind of comes out but a lot of it is not
shown you know it's either shown in like
comic panels or it's told in voiceover
because I guess they couldn't really
afford
shoot it so the end of it is cool like
the end of it is really gory and stuff
but I do feel like the a story this that
had this many moving parts like should
have been a little bit longer so they
could have fleshed out because the thing
is it's like I didn't really there was
no characterization like they didn't
really tell you exactly like what all
these characters yeah you didn't know
who did till I give their fates so it
doesn't it was just like a bunch of
faceless people pretty much yeah so it
doesn't really hit you the same way it
would if it was like an entire season of
The Walking Dead and they had built you
did built up a bunch of interest
invested about you interested in these
characters then maybe it would hit you
directly that's what you know I knew
they are yeah these are just like random
people that are in a jail cell and
they're just like oh you saw cuz you did
this and you suck so now we're just
gonna deal with you and then like 10
minutes like you're different yeah who
cares you know these people you know
what I mean you're right but I'll tell
you what the effects were good it yet
have a gruesome end to the people yeah
so it did deliver what it could within
the time frame yeah it's just an
emotionally you didn't really care it
could have been a bit long and you'd say
anything yeah and you've seen this kind
of stuff before it just would have been
something out of The Walking Dead yeah
something that not negan would have done
but the other guy won before negan when
the governor the governor it's like so
definitely seems like something that it
would have been something that the
governor you know what and here's
something that I didn't realize cuz like
I watched this two times like I usually
do for their review I didn't realize
this the first time that I watched the
episode but the second time I watched it
these two stories even though they seem
unrelated are related because at the end
of the first segment member and I said
the woman had the monkey's paw on her
last wish she wanted to bring her
husband back from the dead then she went
in the morgue and said get up or wake up
or whatever it was she said and didn't
specify she just wanted him to get up
said everyone works that up yeah it is
so then the next story at the be game
they said when she got to talking about
oh the zombie apocalypse she's like oh
we didn't know why it happened like all
these dead bodies just started getting
up because she made that wish
so I thought that was kind of like a
cool little tie-in that I didn't really
notice the Friday the second time I
watched it I was like oh okay and I was
kind of that was pretty amusing
yeah but yeah so that was episode five
like I said probably the weakest one so
far but still pretty good I think next
week is the last one so then we're gonna
have to like get in doing some other
reviews and stuff like that but like I
said you know can't win them all but
this this one's still pretty decent but
it's probably my least favorite of the
season so far
you
oh right the second movie we watched
this week was in Netflix original I
guess or Netflix exclusive that was an
original they did it did have a brief
theatrical yeah it had a brief
theatrical release but I tell you what
ma'am this is Eddie Murphy's comeback
movie that's a good way this movie was
[ __ ] badass is called Dolomites is my
name yes and it has Wesley Snipes in it
uh-huh
and and and everybody else there's a
bunch of other actors in that person
rock cameos yeah no cameos and pretty
much everybody knocks it out of the park
in this movie I loved this movie this
movie is kind of very much like it's
been very the premise is a lot like Ed
Wood yeah it's like the Ed Wood
blaxploitation exploitation and I don't
like using the word blaxploitation I'll
test story in a bit but it is very much
kind of like the story and it's
hilarious as hell all right the story of
a man struggle to create film yeah but
it's not just film he starts off doing
albums at all concert this is this
character and he I forgot what's his
name his name is Roy Grady Rudy ray
Moore Rudy ray Moore it's not really I
guess it's kind of a biopic but it's not
really a biopic in the sense that it's
about his whole life it's just kind of
about it's mostly about him yeah trying
to make the big Rudy ray Moore and it in
Eddie Murphy portrays Rudy in any new
Rudy yeah
back 15 years ago they hung out and Rudy
just wanted to go on tour he didn't you
know he goes Eddie let's go on tour you
know together and it he was like nah man
we need to make a movie about you and
he's like nobody wants to hear about me
but turns out little did he know little
did he know this movie is [ __ ] a
badass flick in the same way that Ed
Wood was a badass flick yeah although
this one is oh is a lot funnier I would
think but it's funny because it's just a
different way of being you that I think
that's very much two different times and
you know what I mean two different
cultures yeah so but it's just a [ __ ]
bad-ass flick
and I don't know it this one that this
one is this one is Eddie Murphy's just
tour-de-force
this is a great mood and I've been an
Eddie Murphy fan for since I was a
teenager it made me really happy to see
him in this because he was like this is
like a really big come back role for him
and you can tell that this was like a
passion project yeah cuz like I said he
knew Rudy ray Moore yeah and he is like
fascinated by the story of how the movie
Dola make Dolomites got made and like
the whole backstory like behind it like
how Rudy ray Moore II start he was like
working in a record store and he was
like kind of a crappy comedian like an
emcee at this club yeah just shake
dancer you know and it was like really
trying real 2-bit kind of guy yeah and
he was like trying to make records and
stuff like that but he's kind of like
old fashioned and he was like really
trying to try to make a name for being a
star yeah and like he had done all these
other things and it wasn't really
working out and [ __ ] like that so in a
way like the movie is you know I'm sure
they leave out like more problematic
parts of his biography I don't really
know but it's almost kind of like it's a
really optimistic movie because it's not
only shows how he like reinvented
himself as this other character just
haven't dominated his scene but how he
like actually got a movie made like with
he got like all his friends together and
he got like all of this film crew from
like yeah old school or something like
that and on the back of the cult success
of this movie he had basically no
support it did it on his own
on the back of this I think he did seven
more I think there were seven and he did
I don't think the first time did a whole
bunch of comedy records and it never hit
a nationwide audience it was always you
know african-american audience and it
was kind of like a cult thing for them
yeah you know and I didn't know anything
about it although a friend of mine told
me I don't like using the word
blaxploitation I'm wouldn't win when
when I lived in Mississippi I used to go
to French Quarter every weekend go down
to Gough
down there on [ __ ] Decatur Street
okay and I ran into this old guy saw a
black guy he was my dad's age so he was
in his late 50s early 60s back then okay
the name is Larry yeah also known as
Larry - pimp that's it that's who he was
back in the 70s and he loved the goth
scene he's a [ __ ] love me - how I
dressed he's like man I should have been
happy that's why that what it worked you
know that kind of stuff you know he kind
of he understood he understood I guess
you can say you know stood the the goth
aesthetic and how that could work you
know and he he loaned me some books
okay the iceberg slim books and there
was some other ones that I read and they
were they were really good and he told
me about Blacula all right and I ended
up seeing a moving loved it but he told
me he says white people call this
blaxploitation but it wasn't
blaxploitation it was just people making
movies that we wanted to see yeah so
during those days people in the white
media labeled these movies as
blaxploitation but they weren't they
were just black theater yeah it was the
movies that black people wanted to see
and this movie gets into that issue
because they were seeing movies that
white people wanted to see and they were
just like this is why it's funny
really they're talking about you guys
yeah it's right it was yeah it was
go ahead a time machine me and J we
wouldn't want to see that we've actually
watch the Dolomites movie yeah okay
because they were pretty [ __ ] boring
but yeah but what had no Larry
Larry's retired Larry got too old to be
a pimp you know and he became a bank
robber now he's serving the rest of his
life behind bars
that was his retirement plan you know he
didn't really time it run out very sick
evening out with a blast
yeah kill anybody but he got a lot of
time got caught on his first one but
yeah that's how and he talked about
dolomite but I didn't know what the hell
he was talking about he told me about
this guy he's kind of like well he
kind of like a folk character is a folk
character but he talked about these Rudy
Raymond war films yeah and he asked me
if I'd seen him he kept telling me to
see them the only one that I actually
saw was black black black and screen
black of the scream yeah which was good
too yeah I have them both on blu-ray
yeah I think computer right and I even
talked about Larry then yeah that's
that's why I you know that's why I want
like I said I've seen the first
Dolomites but I don't think I've seen
any of the other ones although I very
well may have because I try to see all
of those like exploitation place yeah
today cuz all of those yeah like I said
they were not exploitation though they
were just their label battle
retrospective yeah it's just an easy
thing listen you know what you're
talking about when you say that but it's
actually oh that's a that's the white
man putting a label on it yeah it was
just [ __ ] much later is how they kind
of called everything that like there's
none sploit asian us but it was like
yeah
Nazis ploy tation yeah joke became a
joke these like Australian ones they
called auscultation you know just like
they just added that yeah everything
just because it sounded funny yeah but
yeah this one is definitely a must-see
this is a really really really like I
said it's just it's not only just this
this whole like optimistic it's funny as
[ __ ] yeah like everybody that's in it is
good I think Wesley Snipes he's like in
it he plays um you know the guy that
he's the director of the movie the
director of the movie he was got like
kind of is and he does a great job at it
he doesn't really great job at it and I
saw some interviews with with with
Wesley after this movie and he was just
thrilled absolutely honored to work with
Eddie and to be in this movie he [ __ ]
loved this movie and they're doing
coming to America too and it's the same
director and they said to them they said
they've been listening to what everybody
says and they said this is gonna be done
right it's good well yeah like it's
gonna be whatever everybody that was
there know everybody that was in coming
to
America that is still alive is going to
be in it then okay they're including
James Hill Jones he's gonna be in it
well [ __ ] sexual chocolates gonna be in
it fridge is gonna be and everybody's
going to be in this movie and it is not
gonna be one of these newfangled movies
this is going to be an old-school comedy
movie it's gonna go the same way
Chappelle's been going it's gonna and
it's the way this movie went this movie
the writing in it was traditional comedy
writing from my point of view there's a
traditional comedy right yeah and great
traditional storytelling and when you
when you get I recommend this movie to a
bunch of people who saw it and they got
right back to mountain on Facebook
everybody's loved it everybody's loved
it like I and it seems like it's gotten
almost universal acclaim I mean like all
the reviews I've heard at this I think
like 99 percent of them have been like
rapturously positive and I've even a
couple of them even were like saying oh
maybe Eddie Murphy might get like an
Oscar nod which would not shock me at
all like I said the cast in this is just
so good and you can like tell that
everybody was just so excited I work on
this project it's a great story it's
just like a great you come out of the
story walking on air it's a very much of
a feel-good story it is yeah and and it
had all the trials and tribulations of a
guy trying to meet a movie yeah you know
and it's a guy with limited means to
make a movie but he's got a lot of good
friends and he pulls a lot of slick
moves to get it done yeah yeah and yeah
I'm not gonna steal movies Thunder I'm
not gonna really gonna talk about movies
like I said his character and I can see
why Eddie Murphy wanted to do this story
because I mean Rudy ray Moore was such
you know he was just such a determined
individual and it's just like you see
you can feel like his frustration at the
beginning it's like he would not only
haven't any money oh yeah you really
wanted to make something of himself and
he's tried this that and the other thing
it is like nothing was working right
like finally he hits on this you know
dolomite character and it's like a huge
success and he like starts making
records and they start selling all these
copies and then he starts thinking to
himself is like you know it's big but
I'm just like a cult figure I want to be
like massive I want everybody to know
who I am so he's like I have to make a
movie yeah and that's kind of like this
is a very fast-paced yeah very fast but
I said it's not like a biopic in the
sense where it's just like well but it's
because it's very much focused around
the making of dolomite like I know it
has that a comedy packed a lot of
character development in it a lot of
interesting characters lots of little
stories and tales of people having hard
times and coming out of hard times and
making something you know and having
triumphs just a good flick man just a
good flick it is it's a really like
feel-good movie is it want to see it
again already yeah so do I it's just
it's got like a great heart to it and
it's just really [ __ ] anybody money
is [ __ ] yeah like you know what I mean
it's and it's like the kind of funny
that you know back in the old days that
they were doing like that kind of cult
comedy were like they couldn't play it
on the radio or anything like that it
was too dirty
so it's that kind of thing too so it's
got a real kind of like filthy undertone
which I was really right but when I was
back in high school man I just came up
on the old school Eddie Murphy with the
raw @de lyric never wrong delirious his
SNL stuff and then and then um Beverly
Hills Cop yeah 1 & 2 a [ __ ] love them
coming to America the golden child all
that really good classic Eddie Murphy
stuff now later on
oh and [ __ ] I like to have vampire in
Brooklyn I love that now later on his
stuff con I mean he was okay at Tower
Heist even though I didn't like that
movie yet I thought Eddie did a good job
in it but he said he's been on the couch
for five or six years and then he had to
jump up off the couch and he made this
and on the back of this okay from what
they're saying about what they're doing
right now with coming to America too
coming to America too is gonna blow it
out of the [ __ ] water they said
they've been online hearing peoples in
it they're not be like this oh I know
you're not going to do this
please don't make a movie like this they
know exactly what people want they're
gonna give us what we want because some
people people from our generation grew
up with that [ __ ] you have certain
expectations yeah for it for us for the
sequel to coming to America it's got to
deliver and they have promised us a
badass flick and on the back of this
seeing this one I think they got does
that what's good - it actually does give
me hope because this is a really and
just really good movie it just feels
good to have Eddie Murphy back he's just
he's just [ __ ] great in this I mean
like I said I mean this is the comeback
to end all come yeah excellent [ __ ]
movie you're not seeing this movie
you're [ __ ] wrong go check it out you
guys like I said it had a very brief
theatrical run but it just dropped on
Netflix probably just like a week or two
ago yeah it's a great yeah dolomite is
my name so especially if you like like a
70s cinema like filmmaking anything like
that if you like it would ya you'd love
this movie yeah this is kind of like it
you know a different take on that yeah
like think of it it's like the
afro-american Ed Wood yes yeah
definitely go check this one out
okay and the third one we went to the
theater to see it and I'd actually been
wanting to see this cuz you know goth
kid yeah out of his family not bad good
movie in Whitley was a little bit was
better than I expected
yes yeah and it was very gothic oriented
for goth gen-xers would know exactly
what the movies talking about and it did
it did hold true to the original intent
of the Addams Family series yeah where
the Adams has moved into a basically a
haunted mansion right outside of
mainstream town called assimilation yeah
and that's really what that'll that's
really what the Addams Family and the
Munsters were about were about dealing
with the issues that some people did not
assimilate yet they were different than
mainstream society therefore they were
gothic in a way they had that which
although some people might say that
that's another form of conformity but
not really it's just uh but no it did
kind of hold true to the original ideas
behind the Addams Family and but I
thought there's a little delivery was
good Act
Boise acting was great animation was
really good it's a good story
yeah they um you know so Oscar Isaac was
the most Gomez yeah Charlize Theron was
mark Tisch Morticia yeah fin wolf hard
firm stranger things and it's chapter
one was Pugsley yeah and Chloe grace
Moretz was Wednesday now I have to say
and this is probably true of the
original show in the original cartoon
Wednesday was the best character easily
yeah by far although my only gripe about
the movie was Wednesday you know why why
Wednesday was not very cute she looked a
little bit more like because what they
did we this one which I kind of liked
was they went back to the look of more
like the look of the original Charles
Addams cartoons from the nineteen
exactly she was drunk in New Yorker
cartoons
similarly okay she was drawn very much
like that
when I think of Morticia as Adams I'm
actually thinking of like Christina
Ricci's interpret Wednesday I mean you
see me yeah Wednesday let's think of
more of Christina Ricci's interpretation
yeah I mean so she was kind of cute and
that character makes more sense when
she's cute but in this one she's drunk
drawn just super kind of like a bubble
head yes and the other females out out
of this one like member the little the
little mainstream girl that becomes her
friend yeah she's cute yeah and she
actually goes goth and ends up look at
modern god with the shaved head she
looked at him side by side what it means
in animation is that Wednesday Addams
was ugly
yeah and that didn't really that really
cuz in in the TV series she was she was
cute
yeah and that's really a that was the
only thing that I went that I went like
that's not really what the original TV
series it was like but like I said they
were going all over the common they went
more for the comics like the original
comic panels yeah that Charles Addams
true for The New Yorker
oh not exactly but they're they're way
more like reminiscent of that than they
were
although Morticia was drawn as as
attractive yeah you know and she was
attractive in the in the television
series too she was kind of attractive
and this but kind of in a skeletal kind
of a way yeah they made her very very
like skinny yeah too skinny if he asked
me we're talking about damn [ __ ]
cartoon we're tell my cartoon characters
so but I think that I think Oscar Isaac
did a great job let's go back he knocked
it out apart I really liked him and also
the way it's animated the way he looked
yeah that's the way Gomez what I looked
I think yeah I didn't really think that
Uncle Fester
looks like my idea of Uncle Fester all
time with his big ol long hook no sort
of big sausage knows like I said id
drawn like that he had that in the oh I
have like a book of Charles Addams
cartoons I have to look it up because I
can't remember exactly what they look
like but they but I remember when I saw
the trailer now the interesting thing
about this I was
ourselves like Oh Adam some like
anything Adams family I want to see that
chick because I love it but when I first
saw the trailer I was like mmm I don't
know I don't know if that looks good or
not like not so much like I thought it
like the look of it was cool but I
didn't I don't know I like it's worth
seeing I thought the tone of it was
weird but worth seeing um the thing that
I thought was kind of neat about this I
was expecting it to be it's a kids movie
like it's PG but yeah it's not as much
of a kids movie as I was expect right
like in a way like it's not because you
know how a lot of kids movies and I
don't mind this because I like animated
movies and stuff but a lot of them are
like really fast-paced and zany and you
know there's all these like you know
long sequences of like people falling on
their asses and like fighting into it
there's really none of that no not
really it's it's almost kind of like
paced like a normal movie like it's kind
of like you know slow and there's
conversations and it's not too wacky you
know what I mean it is an adult movie it
has a kid subtext yeah kid can interpret
it like there were a couple kids in
there matter of fact it was just we saw
Hurley yeah it was like - and absolutely
absolutely just me and Jenny and then a
mother with two kids I think it was
ticket no - the kids were quiet as
health of the whole thing they liked it
yeah you know I mean they were I was
like oh they're gonna be making all
kinds of noise but no they didn't they
didn't they were like oh wow yeah you
know so they liked it but they didn't
really they didn't get the deeper
meanings of the movie about like
assimilation and you know conformity to
societal norms they didn't really get
what that was all about and then if you
find out that the woman that is
preaching all this conforming to
societal norms is a criminal yeah this
you know this you see uh he's a bigger
freak yeah Adams a bunch of freaks but
the atoms aren't doing anything wrong
they're not anything wrong yeah that's
like super cool and in a way like I kind
of I mean I've always been like super
charmed by the Adams family I mean
probably like most people have who's
growing up like I says Morticia was like
my spirit animal you know what I mean
and I just used to love the show but
because I love the whole thing about the
show because the Addams Family were you
know they weren't me they were very like
good-hearted they just really liked
spooky [ __ ] and you know they liked
blowing their own house up and they had
like well they planted they threatened a
lot of [ __ ] about what we're gonna hang
this person actually that never happens
and stuff like that so so you you're
into it and you can see like how the
like the normal people are like the bad
guys you know what I mean
which I which I was kind of related to
because I'm always but they weren't the
normal people weren't the bad guys in
this mainly that was just a leader of
the yeah while they were because they
kind of like all fell in behind her in
like yeah but is this story that normal
people realized that hey they're just
like is just like you know we've been
fooled by this woman telling us that
they were monsters but they're actually
just like but they're actually just so I
like that part in the movie because it
and it didn't condemn society as a whole
it just condemned the leadership of that
society the way that it was being spun
yeah they were using basically kind of
like fake news on the Internet to [ __ ]
demonize people yeah that's one thing
that yeah she was going on the internet
tell it like spreading Australia's the
rumors that weren't more true about them
and stuff that using which is that kind
of goes back to the satanic panic era I
was very much reminded of that yeah but
like I said you know if you're if you're
into goth culture there will be a lot of
you will know exactly what y'all know
exactly what this is about and also I
like that there was some jokes and there
were a little bit adult like it wasn't
like right at the beginning because this
has a little bit of like a prequel
because you get to see we're driven now
the old kind yeah because like Gomez and
Morticia it's like their wedding yeah
like in the old country and then like
all the villagers come with all the
torches you know and everything and they
have to run away and they how they find
lurch and everything like that before
they you know up to the house that they
you know kind of yeah famous for and
[ __ ] like that so I thought that was
kind of cool and another thing that I
thought was cool was that at the very
end they did an animated version of the
opening from the TV show yeah
60s like it's exactly the same solvent
animated but yeah I thought that was
really cool but then was like a lot of
really cute [ __ ] in this like I said
like right near the beginning like Uncle
Fester they're all like climbing up the
mountain like to get away from the
villagers and Uncle Fester says
something like oh I can see my house
from here
oh no that's a women's prison it did
have kind of a dark feeling to it there
were certain areas where it kind of felt
a little spooky inside the house because
the house it just keeps going get out
it's a haunted house there's nothing
that a kid couldn't handle it had good
visuals yeah it's scary and it's also
not super deep this would have been when
I was in my 20s I would love to have
like smoking a joint and when it was
this movie yeah yeah oh what a stainless
see it again like I feel like the
live-action ones you know they had raúl
juliá and Angelica yeah yeah we're
probably better like this one is kind of
like it this one's kind of lightweight I
think so compared to that but you know I
I really liked the animation I liked the
look of the inside of the house I'd like
to like all the voice acting was really
good and I liked that they went back to
the kind of more original look of the
characters I thought that was a cool
idea you know what I mean but I had a
good time with it there's really nothing
wrong with it yeah there was nothing
wrong with it it's just a fun my only
gripe was is that my version of
Wednesday Addams Wednesday thank you it
was cute she wasn't conscious she was
cute in this but yeah she's gonna bubble
a head it was mayhem she had a bubble
head it was kind of weird with no neck
next to the her friend that she met who
got out in those equipment Wednesday
should probably look like that Parker
was the yeah Parker yeah Wednesday
should have looked more like when is it
like when Wednesday wanted to go to
regular middle school or yeah yeah I
think that was the best part look at the
science class and everything I'm like
and also all the [ __ ] she talked to like
the other students that were they all
Gomez though they did Neil go like I
said Oscar Isaac and they nailed Pugsley
yeah I think pretty much they nailed
lurch
did a really good job of lurch cousin it
was played by dog you can't really tell
the grandma yeah that was Bette Midler I
think yeah
yeah the mortician of the voice of
mortician the character never Charlize
Theron I didn't really think that the
way the animated character looked was
quite right but alright whatever
that's yeah they're gonna do it like I
said they did a lot more like the
cartoonist yeah and I kind of like that
you know I kind of like that it's that
you know this was just like a super fun
and especially like I said if you're an
old if you're an old guy like I am and I
grew up watching The Addams Family show
and also a big book of the cartoons cuz
I always really liked all our guy
friends and they got DJ Mouse she went
like oh no you guys see this one this is
a good one
or that yeah this is for all the old
goth kids check it out don't be so
you'll you'll definitely like season
stuff in there that you'll relate to I
mean I certainly did but yeah so you
know take the kids it's it's a fun time
you